this is
andrew sullivan's piece yesterday and
actually zach could you show that
the screenshot i sent of his tweet
and then could you enlarge this is a
quote
from uh boy i can read it
yeah you would you read it so what am i
reading though is this andrew
yes this is andrew sullivan this is a
quote from andrew sullivan
this is andrew sullivan in his piece
posted yesterday and this seems to me to
be the key question here do we really
want to get back to living
i do so take the rational precautions a
solid vaccine
and go about your business as you always
did yes i'll wear a mask indoors if i'm
legally required or politely asked
but i don't really see why anyone should
in a free society once everyone has
access to a vaccine
that overwhelmingly prevents serious
sickness and death there is no reason to
enforce lockdowns again
or mask mandates or social distancing
any longer
in fact there's every reason not to
so what i wanted to say and i uh this is
offered
with um full respect andrew i really
like a lot of what you say and frankly i
understand and resonate with the point
that you are making here
i get it but i don't think it's right
because it's predicated on a couple of
things
that aren't accurate so
you are imagining that you are being
asked a cdc yesterday or
the day before said that it wanted
people who had been vaccinated
to wear masks why that's the question
now the answer that many people are
arriving at the answer that i believe we
are being led to is that you are wearing
them to protect
unvaccinated people and there is a
degree of truth in
your wearing a mask protects
unvaccinated people
but i think the clearest reason why you
are being asked to wear a mask is to
protect
you a vaccinated person from the escape
variants that we now see circulating
and secondly from uh do you want to jump
um the first reason for you to wear a
mask as a vaccinated person
is to protect you against the escape
variants which
are on the rise and about which
the vaccines with which you've already
been vaccinated are very little
protection
are very little protection which points
to selection
exerted by those vaccines on the virus
so we are ultimately going to find
ourselves in an argument about
evolutionarily why we are seeing
variants now what their implication is
but the fact that those variants
are good at creating breakthrough cases
among the vaccinated implies selection
by those vaccines has produced these
variants
that's one reason that you need to be
protected at this moment more
than the cdc recognized you did a month
ago
the second reason has to do with the
fading of the immunity
from the vaccines so these vaccines it
turns out not only do they provide a
narrow immunity but they also provide a
short-lived immunity
that appears to fade so in oh
go ahead uh well i thought you wanted to
show
this evidence as well as your third
reason yeah there's and i was going to
say there is
there is also a third reason so in
your piece andrew you repeat
a piece of wisdom that has been almost
universally embraced
and this piece of wisdom is the vaccines
protect you from getting an infection
they are not perfect
they also protect you from getting
sick protect you from getting very sick
if you do contract a breakthrough
infection now what we want to call your
attention to
is a piece that emerged two days ago
yeah two or three two or three days ago
on sub stack
uh by a creature euphemistically called
okay um what zach showed my screen when
i was not ready for it to be shown
that's all right okay
um yeah this was published by dr roller
gator
who i should point out is not
actually a phd as far as i know he's
also not an actual alligator and
his leather jacket is fake but his
analysis this is a person who has
published a very serious analysis
of these so this is a person you know to
be a real person yes alligator
i do know him to be a person and a
ferociously high quality intellect
but anyway he has a uh an ironic
personality on twitter which he is using
for his sub stack as well
in any case it is an analysis of the
question of the benefits of the vaccines
and what he
posits here based on a thorough
mathematical analysis
that appears to us at least to be robust
is
uh the question about what the vaccines
do in the case of breakthrough cases do
they
reduce the likelihood of getting
seriously ill
so if i could have my screen back for a
minute zach i was just looking something
up um
what he is if i can just i'm just going
to read the section here rather than
us yeah um so this is this is now from
our piece that we published yesterday
the little bit of it in which we are
talking about his
um in this off-sited study um
which is hassetal 2021 looking at the
effectiveness of the two-dose pfizer
vaccine in israel they purport to find
extremely high effectiveness against
both infections and in breakthrough
cases in reducing hospitalization severe
disease and death and that that is the
work
that has been transmuted into the into
the mainstream media
and the largely the reason why
um people who are vaccinated feel safe
um not just against getting the disease
once they're vaccinated but
um in having a reduced a reduced case of
it should they get a breakthrough case
but but dr rollergater here provides an
analysis
in which he finds that
it is true that the risk of infection
is far lower in vaccinated than in
unvaccinated individuals
however if a person is both vaccinated
and infected
the correct math reveals no reduction in
deaths compared to being unvaccinated
and unless you are old and with regard
to hospitalizations there is a tiny
reduction in hospitalization for the
uh 45 to 64 year olds and
a larger reduction for the old but for
people under 45
again no reduction at all so let's just
show his his graphs here this is regard
to
with regard to death the probability of
covet 19 related death if infected
for ages 16 to 14 um basically the
um the confidence interval i
think this is i'm not remembering um is
much broader for the vaccinated but
um but they're effectively the same
thing
and that is to say their their mean is
the same
yep and um for
uh hold on so that was 16 to 44 year
olds
uh for 45 to 64 year olds
there is a
you know it looks like a slightly higher
rate of death if you're vaccinated but
really the
you know the numbers are are sloppy
enough that there's no reason to think
that that is true
but there's certainly no protective
effect um if you get a breakthrough case
um
but that's but that flips um for the
for the old for 65 years and older
people
you do indeed have both and this is just
deaths and i'm not going to
scroll through and find the
hospitalization graphs that that he has
produced here
but if you're over 65 and you get a
breakthrough case
uh because you're vaccinated but you get
exposed to covenant breakthrough case
um being vaccinated does um
does predict a better outcome with
regard to you not dying and you're not
being hospitalized
but for people younger than that that
pattern
falls apart right so let's say
this work has just emerged it will be
interesting to see if anyone finds a
flaw in it but
the basic point that uh that this paper
makes
is that in fact what we are being given
is something like a sales pitch
in which the reduction in deaths and
hospitals paper relegators paper yes
relegators giving a sales pitch no he is
alleging that we are being given a sales
pitch
and the sales pitch is that you have a
reduced
likelihood of infection a reduced
likelihood of severe disease and a
reduced likelihood of
hospitalization and death when in fact
those are the same reduction
that is to say if you don't get coveted
you obviously won't go to the hospital
for covet and you won't die of covet but
it is not
that if you get an infection you also
have a much reduced likelihood of these
things
you don't unless you're in this very old
age group
right exactly so you know effectively
then the way
that the numbers were analyzed um
amounts to either um
just a naive misunderstanding of how
they should have been analyzed
or hopefully not an intentional
uh erroneous signal put into the world
right but but
i think the the point about uh andrew
sullivan's piece
is that you can see even in that quote
that we read
that what he is imagining is that
he's going to go about his life and if
he gets a case
it's going to be much reduced and so why
should he be wearing a mask and the
answer is a
because your likelihood of getting a
case is going up as a result of the
fading of the vaccine immunity
as a result of the narrowness of that
immunity and the
variants that are now uh increasingly
dominating the pandemic
and the benefit that he's imagining
should he get a case
is likely to be uh
close to non-existent if this analysis
is correct yeah
so he's not he's not elderly right so i
guess the sum total of all of this the
way i would sum it up
is i believe we have to recognize that
we have been
given a bunch of intuitive sounding
wrong
things that many people believe right we
are
facing increasing frustration and in
fact i believe
we can see an orchestrated campaign to
blame the unvaccinated
for the continuing pandemic as if there
was ever a plan
in which these vaccines were going to
end the pandemic which is inconceivable
in light of the fact
that even if you were to vaccinate all
of the western world
you couldn't reach the entire world with
these things which meant there was going
to be large populations
that were going to continue to have this
virus so you needed effectively
sterilizing vaccines that were rolled
out simultaneously everywhere
and um and you know i hope that
um we all wish that we had sterilizing
facts absolutely
um and you know we arrived at the
pandemic with the vaccines that showed
up
sort of um and you know still hoping for
you know
good solid sterilizing vaccines to show
up that would be great
um but also the way that these vaccines
were rolled out at least in the u.s
was very slow and
if yeah you know you will remember it
was you know it's healthcare there were
all these tears it was healthcare
workers first and the elderly and people
with comorbidities and people were
were you know vying to to break rank and
and get vaccinated early but there just
wasn't enough to go around
and had the goal been to eradicate the
virus and stop the pandemic
there would have been a concerted effort
to to
wait until there was enough vaccine
supply and concentrate the vaccine
rollout so that as
many people as possible got vaccinated
all at once
as opposed to providing this sort of
rolling target
for selection to act on right and so you
can imagine it like if we really had
non-corrupt highly competent public
health
authorities you would imagine that as
painful as it would be to delay
vaccination because of course there
would be lives lost in the interim
that there would have been a delay to
allow a sudden
uh deployment of the vaccines
universally there would have been
special guidance
around how to behave while you were
developing immunity
so even in the case of a sterilizing
vaccine the period of time in which
you're developing immunity
is a hazard so you know you know i did
see i mean that
the guidance was until you are
considered fully immunized which was
uh two weeks after your final um shot if
you got the two-shot uh vaccine
you need to behave as if you're not well
but behave as if you're not doesn't
doesn't begin to cover it
um so my point is we could have really
high quality guidance
and the really high quality guy we could
have really high quality vaccines maybe
that's
harder to get to yeah i'm not we don't
know
we don't know but we should we should
certainly we hope that there is r
d um under g going on
right now for high quality sterilizing
vaccines would be lovely but it would
also be lovely to imagine that there's
not going to be a fight between
manufacturers over whose vaccine has the
market and that that fight is going to
have very little to do with which
vaccines are best for humanity i hate to
say it that may sound cynical but given
what i've seen
uh i i would expect jockeying for
position
endemic profiteering right pandemic
profiteering is what i was expect would
expect
but you could imagine very brief
guidance right that you would get
vaccinated you would coordinate with
your family maybe and you know isolate
completely for some period of time
i i don't know what the we we would
really want high quality analysis
um but you could imagine a campaign but
this campaign does not look like it was
designed in any way
that anyone could have imagined it was
going to end the pandemic and yet that's
kind of been the implication
that we would have ended the pandemic if
only it weren't for the holdouts
and that's just nonsense it can't be
[Music]
right
you